julia back joins us now onset julie
thanks very much for coming on
thanks for having me so you said
something that i think many people would
in their hearts think is obvious but
very few people are willing to say
out loud you said it knowing you would
likely be punished for saying it but you
said it anyway why did you do that
i believe in the truth i believe that
people should have these conversations
and say
things that matter without a fear
of um punishment you are old-fashioned
why do you think i couldn't agree with
you more and i'm grateful that you have
that attitude
but why do you think it was important to
say this specifically
well when we get down to it women and
girls all share a biological reality
we are all female but if any man if any
male
person can call himself a woman or
legally identify as female then
predatory men will do so
in order to gain access to women's
single sex spaces and this puts every
woman and girl at risk
that's from the beginning i don't weigh
in on this often because sexual politics
is a morass and it's it's not worth it
to be totally honest with you but i have
enough daughters that i i care and my
instinct has always been
this change in our society which we
never debated the terms have never been
clarified
is not going to be good for girls in the
long run do you share that concern
i definitely do agree um like i said
this puts every woman and girl at risk
of male violence and this is already
happening in many states
in many states men can legally identify
themselves as female
and gain access to women's single-sex
spaces and
sports is just one institution where men
are taking
titles scholarships and this is a
problem
so it's it seems like a real problem why
wouldn't
women's groups who exist to carry the
banner for women
raise the alarm about this women have
been speaking out about this for
decades but we have been effectively
silenced
many women like myself have been pushed
out of spaces that
that we built spaces that are intended
to include us
simply because we acknowledge biological
reality
do you think um i mean you're a lesbian
you were in the same acronym as a bunch
of
other groups including people who are
transgendered
do you think that makes it more
difficult for you to make this argument
i mean
it seems like this has been so
politicized that you're expected to have
a certain set of views that maybe you
don't have
i see where you're coming from i would
like to make a distinction
here the letters in the acronym share
not much the lg and b are based on
sexualities they're based on sex
biological realities
yes but the t is based on gender
identity
which is not based in biological reality
in fact i would
argue that it's opposed to biological
reality the lgb
is very different from the t and i don't
think it's fair to lump us all into the
same
do you do you find it astounding that it
is considered an
act of bravery to defend biology
i wouldn't say so myself but it's i
guess that's where we are right now
and i hope more women stand up
last question because i can't say what
did they say to you you were thrown off
this commission you're punished
for saying this out loud what was the
rationale for it
frankly there was no case made my
accuser
said that they didn't have to make a
case um
one of the members of my committee
argued that sex was a thing of the past
he said
frankly science had progressed so far
that sex was
import unimportant um i argued the
opposite
we'll be back in a time like this
everyone thinks so i would i would say
what i really think but most people
are afraid to and you're not and and i'm
definitely upstanding an admiration of
that thank you for that thank you for
having me